All right. We missed hatred mail last week
because of the David Pakman show staff summer
vacation, but it is back. Quick Reminder.
What is hatred? Mail
teachers can buy their own school supplies,
but we'll throw in the Glock for free.
Hey, [inaudible] written by patriots. Who
Hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom,
this, this week's Patriot male introduces,
um, a notable term. Let me put it that way.
Let's take a listen to it.
Hey, beefing bets. Clickbait pacman. Once
again, don't you ever learn? I'm generally
unsubscribing. How bout you hop off buddy?
Anybody can see what you're doing. Nothing
personal. But you are a Jew. A pretty obvious
Jew at that. Yes, you're white David, because
Ashkenazi Jews are actually Italians. You're
a Spanish speaking Italian. Who thinks he's
a Jew? Must be tough kid.
I'm an obvious Jew. That's interesting. So
I guess the implication is that there would
be subtle Jews and then there are obvious
Jews. I'm in the latter category. Apparently.
Uh, the best way to fight hatred, autism in
your local community is to become a member@joinpacman.com
utilizing the coupon code hatred at 40 h a
t r, I, O, t four zero. When you use the coupon
code hatred at 40, you save 40% off of your
membership and hatreds cry because they are
extremely saddened by the fact that their
hatred, autism is only furthering financial
support of the David Pakman show. That's how
I see it anyway. I know that might not literally
be how people see it, but, uh, go to the join
pacman.com pick your membership of choice,
apply the coupon code hatred 40 and get 100%
of the member perks, but with a 40% discount.